[Music]
at the same time the ethical substance
is divided with respect to its form or
to knowing
spirit when acting appears qua
consciousness over against the object to
which its activity is directed and which
consequently is determined as the
negative of the knower the doer finds
himself thereby in the antithesis of
knowing and not knowing
he takes his purpose from his character
and knows it as an ethical essentiality
but on account of the determinateness of
his character he knows only the one
power of substance the other remaining
for him concealed the present reality is
therefore one thing in itself and
another thing for consciousness
the upper and the nether law come to
signify in this connection the power
that knows and reveals itself to
consciousness and the power that
conceals itself and lies in ambush the
one is the aspect of light the god of
the oracle who in accordance with its
natural movement
moment has sprung from the
all-illuminating sun knows all and
reveals all phoebus and zeus who is his
father
but the commands of this truth-speaking
god and his announcements of what is are
really deceptive for this knowing is in
its principle immediately a
not knowing because consciousness in its
action is in its own self this
antithesis
he who is able to unlock the riddle of
the sphinx and he who trusted with
childlike confidence are therefore both
sent to destruction
through what the god revealed to them
this priestess through whom the
beautiful god speaks is in no way
different from the equivocating sisters
of fate who buy their promises drive to
crime those who listen to them and who
buy the double tongue character of what
they announce as a certainty deceive him
who relied on the obvious meaning
the consciousness therefore that is
purer than the latter which believes
witches and is more prudent more solid
and more thorough than the former which
trusts the priestess and the beautiful
god
tarries with his revenge even though the
very spirit of his father reveals to him
the crime by which he was murdered and
institutes still other proofs for the
reason that this revelatory spirit could
also be the devil
in paragraph 737
hegel is now turning away from just
looking at content in halt that has been
divided no longer into a multiplicity
but into two
sides from each other and now he's
looking
at a division or rather an apportioning
is a better way of translating it knock
thailand in the german
into uh different parts of as he says
the form
or in this specific instance the form of
of what the form of acting and
knowing vision so
knowledge and or knowing and acting are
not so radically
dissociated from each other
in hegel as they often are in other
thinkers where we have the theoretical
side and then we have the practical side
we saw this very much so
in the discussion
in the spirit section
leading into the morality
section which was quite long
and we saw this happening particularly
in terms
of the various dynamics leading up
ultimately up to
the
french revolution described in terms of
absolute freedom and the terror right
here it's it's a different context
but
you can say that knowing and acting
are closely associated we often
learn or come to know or acting itself
and acting not just in terms of doing
one action but in terms of sequences of
actions intentional action handling as
the term being used here as opposed to
you know mere tot you know a deed
we often learn things in the action
itself and in tragedy you often learn oh
man did i get things wrong we're going
to hit on those examples in just a
moment hegel is actually moving out of
just references to greek tragedy and
into shakespearean tragedy as well we
could also think of like you know other
things that are on the scene
we could come up with all sorts of other
great examples to to flush this out with
so the
form or the knowing is where there's a
division previous paragraph it talked
about
a division of the content and there we
were looking primarily at the totality
of the tragedy right with two different
main
poles two different powers
here we're looking at a
character a
hero a
you know protagonist
and what it is that they think that they
know
and
what they actually don't know and the
actions that they engage in
on that basis and i will point out that
hegel towards the end of the paragraph
in referencing hamlet
at least as far as miller is concerned i
think this is completely correct
given the other clues that hegel is
providing us with here
we do have an exception to the rule
a character who's not jumping
beyond their knowledge thinking that
they actually have
knowledge of things so let's take a look
at the text this is very
rich passage
at the same time the
in brackets ethical this is miller
substance is divided with respect to its
former knowing so let's stop right there
why did miller translate this as the
ethical substance given that the german
term is actually vason the essence or
being
well
you know there's some decent reason for
this i think this is one of those cases
where miller is
um
being a little bit too prescriptive and
and not letting the reader just read
what are we talking about as this this
vase in this being that gets divided
well there's a couple
different possibilities which are not
completely
divided from each other there's spirit
of course and we're going to see spirit
coming up in the very next few sentences
there is the ethical substance that has
been brought up the ethical substance
referring all the way back to what we're
playing around with and trying to
understand in the
reason and even more in the spirit
section particularly the early part of
the spirit section that hegel has just
referenced in the previous paragraph and
which he is going to reference again in
this paragraph where we have the two
laws
and the tragedy in question is really
the antigone
one that that hegel thought was was very
important
what else could we talk about substance
of course right substance
but also
subject subject
just in the previous paragraph he told
us
right this is towards the end the
previous dispersion of the hole into
manifold and abstract forces
is the dissolution of the subject which
comprehends them only as moments within
itself right so this is this is quite
important and he ended by talking about
characters and that is that that is what
we're getting to
in this point character in a double
sense the character who is the knowing
acting person
for for example uh hamlet or
oedipus or you know macbeth or pick
whoever else you want
and their own character the the
set of
temperaments and ethical dispositions
that they have that defines who they
they are
so
now that we've clarified that let's
let's go on a little bit he says um
here we go
spirit when acting
acting not in the sense of just engaging
in one big deed but in a whole sequence
of coherent consistent action
handle
spirit in acting
appears quoi
consciousness
so consciousness
over against the object to which its
activity is directed and which
consequently is determined as the
negative of the
knower now at this point object
gegenstein
it could be a physical object think
about somebody breaking rocks you know
so that they can
take them and make them into a rock
fence or be because they've been
condemned to a chain gang and stupid
meaningless activity of breaking rocks
or because there's a giant rock that's
standing in the way of plowing a field
and they need to break it up and they
don't have dynamite to do that we could
go on and on there's intentionalities
involved there and there's there's an
acting subject and then there's an
object that is not merely the object of
the action but something that stands
against it gag and stand right it is it
is there
an artist who is carving a statue takes
the wood block or the marble or whatever
it's going to be as the object
they also have an object in a different
sense the zvec or purpose what it is
that they want to turn this into in the
case of a big rock that you want to turn
into little rocks little rocks is the
and and
purpose of it right and maybe you put
them into a wheelbarrow and carry them
away or you turn them into a fence in
the case of the wood block that the
carver is going to turn into a statue of
of pan
playing his
pipes and dancing around that well they
the end point is that statue and then
there can be other ends like well this
is going to be decorative i'm going to
use this in warship or something like
that
so the object stands against the doer
and the knower and the knower knows the
object to some degree it's not a
complete black hole a
total non-entity because otherwise you
can't direct action towards it can you
right
so if we go on he says
the doer so so the the
object is
uh
determined as the negative
of the knower and
what does the doer find themselves in
the antithesis of knowing
and not knowing
here we need to bring up a
once again a issue of translation a
important not only lexical but
conceptual point so antithesis here
is
gegenzotz what we would typically
translate as contradiction
right
although you know wiederspruch
can also be used for that and gagan
gazeta so there's a lot of different
oppositions we have an antithesis which
is not leading to a synthesis it's just
a two things being opposed to each other
which of them is the thesis neither of
them are the thesis they're both
antithesis to each other
knowing
visin right and then not knowing nicht
vissen nichtvisin is an interesting uh
thing to say because it's kind of a an
equivocal term right
knowing not
right knowing that something is not
something else or is not what you
originally thought it was is one way we
could think of this we could also think
of it as simply not knowing you you
uh there are some things that you do
know and there are other things that you
don't know and you don't even know that
you don't know them right they are
unknown unknowns
it can also be
knowing
the not
knowing the negativity of the object and
that's going to happen later on when you
come to the point where you're like holy
crap did i make a mistake
wow this is a big part of
much tragedy there's this reversal that
takes place and it's not just a reversal
of fortune
it's also a revelation of what there is
to be known so for example oedipus let's
take that as the prime case what does
oedipus learn well let's think back
about the story that he's in right
there's a prophecy that little oedipus
is going to
kill his father and marry his mother the
you know people of thieves are like this
is terrible let's get rid of this kid
right and so they he he's abandoned he's
raised by uh if i remember right the
corinthians
and he he leaves so he won't fulfill
that prophecy and he winds up on the way
to thieves and he meets the the sphinx
and we'll talk about that you know later
on and he runs into a guy and this guy's
kind of a jerk and the guy says get the
hell out of my way i'm in my chariot and
oedipus says screw you old man uh you
want it you want to fight and so they do
and oedipus lays him out and then he's
like well
you know i kill a lot of people you know
it's it's kind of a lawless time in
greece let's keep going on to thebes
right
and he gets there and then he finds out
oh
the city is an uproar somebody killed
the king
and you know the queen who is beautiful
is been you know left on her own who
what what are we going to do and oedipus
steps in and he's like yeah you know um
i can be your king and i'll marry this
this you know beautiful woman here and
i'll produce a lineage so that
everything is secure you know two
daughters two sons this is amazing and
then a plague comes to the land and it's
because nobody has taken care of and
punished the killer of the earlier king
leias who turns out is odysseus
oedipus's father right the the husband
of jocasta before oedipus became her
husband and oedipus is like yeah
definitely we've got to punish this guy
you know let's find out what's what and
they even bring in teresius this famous
sage and
oracle
you know a wise man who's got all sorts
of cool stories of his own about like
you know having been a man and a woman
and how he ended up being blind and
stuff like that and edifice says to him
hey you got to tell us the answer to
this because we haven't been able to
find it through our own detective work
and he says i don't think you want the
answer so what do we have here we have
this antithesis of knowing and not
knowing and at this point oedipus
doesn't know in the sense of like
there's information about this object
the thing he wants to do set things
right that's missing and teresius has
that information and eventually reveals
it to him this by the way is not a
totally you know unique trope where else
does it show up in the uh
stories of david in the bible right
after he had bathsheba's husband uriah
the hittite put into the front line so
he could get hit you know him killed and
then take bathsheba into his harem and
then you know another plague comes and
then nathan the prophet you know says
you're the guy you're the one who's
causing this stuff right so
oedipus finds out and what he learns
is not good information right and it's
not good information not just for him
but also for everybody around him we
have joe costa his wife and his mother
um
hanging herself we have oedipus gouging
his own eyes out and abandoning the
kingship to
his his sons his sons who are also his
brothers
we have his two daughters who are going
to get into problems of their own
oedipus actually
leaves and he can't get away because
they still want to use him
in terms of power struggles and things
that are going on it is a
massive
mess produced through action and
knowledge right and so sometimes you
know maybe nate vision is better
but there's also the coming to know the
nothingness of these these things so
let's go on as well
coming back to this right the antithesis
of knowing and not knowing he takes his
purpose who's the he the hero the
character from his character now we're
talking about ethical character
and
knows it as now here's an interesting
term an ethical essentiality right
so
they know his character as an ethical
essentiality zitlika okay that's ethical
vase in height not vasin but vase and
height something that is essential to a
person and because this person is not
just a single person on their own but
rather is you know somebody who's at the
top of their
hierarchy food chain whatever you want
to call it it's going to be an
essentiality for their culture as well
and he says
he takes this purpose from from his
character so the purpose is reaching out
to the object
he says on account of the
determinateness of his character he only
knows the one power of substance the
other remaining for him concealed so
where are these powers coming from this
is the the division within the content
that we saw in the last paragraph he's
on one side or she you know antigone
right
um maybe even
can we can we fold the medea
in here
i don't know i don't know that that fits
the mold
quite as well perhaps it does perhaps it
doesn't that that's that's a good one to
think about
so one one side of the substance the
other side of the substance is over here
the negative the object
the thing that is in itself and now
being talked about as a concealed power
the other power is is remaining for him
concealed
is it remaining concealed for the rest
of the actors in the play yes also them
except for in this case with oedipus
teresius right
so uh he goes out and he says the
present reality
is therefore one thing in itself and
another thing for consciousness we have
the in itself or on zeke right
and we have consciousness over here
reality itself is not all of the reality
that we could know so acting or handling
the spirit
is spread over all of this but the
character only knows a portion of it the
portion that they know
well because it's within the realm of
their consciousness
so he goes on and he says
the upper another law
reference back to the earlier spirit
section right and to the previous
paragraph
uh the upper and lo another law come to
signify in this connection
the power that knows and reveals itself
to consciousness
and the power that conceals itself and
lies in ambush and we're at this point
we're splitting them into two things we
have the upper law the lower law we've
got a problem there an antithesis a
gegenzadz because
law should encompass all of this right
and and each of these laws is struggling
against the other law in a certain sense
they're lawless right
we also have um this entire dynamic
going on
with this concealed power this concealed
substance this concealed essentiality as
well that seems to have its own purposes
so we have the power that knows and
reveals itself to consciousness
this can be the god this can be the
oracle this can also be the character
displaying itself right the hero is kind
of godlike in this respect
and then we have as he says the power
that doesn't just conceal itself
but that lies in ambush
that's that's an interesting way to
think about it
so
up until this point we've been looking
at this as
an object there's a certain passivity on
this side even to talk about the upper
law and the nether law the nether law is
kind of you know
it's below it doesn't act all that much
if it does so it does so in subterranean
ways
lying in ambush
means there's agency there
there's intentionality that is alien
to the knowing and acting consciousness
and it is
also conscious
on its own side but it's not brought
into
consciousness at this point right
so what it what can this be
he says the one is the aspect of light
the god of the oracle who in accordance
with its natural
moment has sprung from the
all-illuminating sun knows all reveals
all phoebus and zeus who is his father
right phoebus apollo god of prophecy you
go to delphi
and you know it's really great because
zeus is you know above the board right
and apollo is like totally transparent
in this respect and you go and ask the
oracle stuff now the oracle's kind of
funny right because the oracle is also
part of these catholic
forces you know she's sniffing in the
fumes coming in from you know what
wherever
and things are being revealed in a cave
and you know and then the answers are
kind of obscure
you can take them if you want to as
being like totally clear but you do so
at your peril
right like hegel says the commands of
this truth speaking god and his
announcements of what is what reality is
are really deceptive
why
well we got this antithesis again this
knowing is in its principle immediately
and not knowing why
because consciousness in its action
is in its own self this antithesis
so the antithesis is not just between
knowing and not knowing on the part of
the character
it is an antithesis that is running
throughout reality itself and part of
the very structure of action
this is uh gonna be
a problem isn't it so
here we see a reference to the sphinx
he who is able to unlock the riddle of
the sphinx the sphinx asks you know uh
this puzzle
and i won't rehearse it because i don't
want to take up too much time but
oedipus answers it right and then the
sphinx is like okay you can go on
and he who trusted with childlike
confidence
are therefore
set to sent to destruction
through what the god revealed to them
and now here's an interesting thing so
um
miller in his translation here he
provides a bunch of footnotes very
unusual for miller
to unpack it this way he wants to say
that he who trusted with childlike
confidence is orestes
if you don't know the story of arrestees
right orestes is the son of agamemnon
and agamemnon is the war leader who
takes the greek host to troy and has to
sacrifice his daughter in order to allow
the ships to pass does so quite a
minister his wife gets really ticked off
about that starts plotting revenge hooks
up with a cousin against these who is
you know connected to agamemnon and
there's bad blood going back several
generations when it comes to that and so
they plot that when he returns they're
going to kill this guy and and to cap it
all off agamemnon comes back and he's
he's got a war captive that he's taken
essentially as a concubine right um and
and she is the prophetess um cassandra
who nobody listens to who says don't go
in there they're gonna kill you right so
he goes in and they say let's let's draw
you a nice bath and in the bathtub clyde
minestra and i guess these kill him and
now orestes has a little dilemma what do
i do man i should i'm supposed to avenge
my dad
but on the other side i'm not supposed
to kill my mom
so what do i do and he does actually end
up doing in clytemnestra and her lover
against these and then he is pursued by
the furies is this really referring to
that story or is this still about
oedipus i don't really know i mean
oedipus has a kind of child-like
confidence as well
so he says therefore both sent to
destruction through what the god
revealed to them i mean there's a lot of
revelations so
and and uh
he goes on he says this priestess
through whom the beautiful god speaks is
in no way different now here he brings
in shakespearean plays from the
equivocating sisters of fate who by
their promises drive to crime those who
listen to them and who by the
double-edged character of what they
announced as a certainty deceived him
who relied on the obvious meaning so you
know the point here
let me just read one well actually yeah
uh we'll just say the point here is
the oracle the god the the
um
assurance
you can't really trust them because they
are actually
on this side just as much as on
your side there is a concealment going
on right
so then he brings up another
possibility
and this is the one associated with
hamlet
the consciousness therefore that is
purer than the latter which believes
which is and is more prudent more solid
and thorough than the former who trusts
the priestesses and the beautiful god
tarries with his revenge even though the
very spirit of his father reveals to him
the crime by which he was murdered and
institutes still other proofs okay so
that's clearly hamlet right that there's
no ancient greek tragedy as far as we
know that corresponds to that and hegel
didn't have any more greek tragedies
than we currently do uh some of them
have been lost actually the vast
majority of them have been lost and
you know we haven't made a lot of
advance on that
so what does hamlet do
hamlet
doesn't act or he acts in a way that
only goes so far
and and he does so because he doesn't
really have full knowledge full
knowledge about
who is to blame full knowledge about
what he ought to do full knowledge of
the consequences
we have another case where there's a
conspirator
conspiracy between uh family members and
that's that's quite problematic and
notice what he says there's another
reason as well for the reason this
revelatory spirit could also be the
devil leading you astray
so
what if the oracle is not beneficent
what if the
ghost of your father isn't really the
ghost of your father but is really a
demon trying to tempt you into doing bad
things
against your your own family
hamlet says yeah i gotta be
kind of careful and what happens to him
does this save him does this save the
people he's involved with i mean if you
read that play almost everybody is dead
at the end so no it's not and then the
house is basically destroyed right so
we have a lot of things going on here
and
there's you know unpacking this division
of the form or of knowledge
sure tells us a lot about tragedy and
about
what the key thematics of it are the
last thing i do want to say is can we
shoehorn all greek tragedy into this
this perspective
i've got my doubts about that i think
you know there are plays that are easier
to do that with and there are plays that
are harder to do that with i has been
thinking as i've been you know talking
here about whether the medea can really
fit this mold
and i'm i'm not sure
that it really
it really fits that well
so that would be one major
uh greek play of massive influence
throughout antiquity
that doesn't fit this but you get where
hegel is going he's following out the
threads that seem to him useful for
illuminating this matter